A question I get asked all the time is
"Luca how can you memorize so many words
across so many languages?" And my simple
answer is: "I build a word spider web", and
in this video, I'm going to give you the
tools to create it, to maintain it, and to
make it stronger. If I say the word "game"
what is the very first thing that comes
to your mind?
Probably something associated with
"play" - playing games - but the reality is
that "game" has many other meanings.
For example, you can say "I was hunting game",
meaning "I was hunting wild animals" or
"Are you game?" - like "are you down?,  do you want to do something?". So this goes to
show that many words have multiple
meanings and functions according to
their context and what gives them meaning? Context, that is, surrounding words.
So, whenever you find a word that you don't
know in a foreign language, always make
sure that you either take the sentence
in which that word is embedded and you
copy it somewhere on your notebook, for
example, or you create your own sentence
in which you embed that word. A very
common mistake is for example to take
all these words that you don't know from
a text and simply put it on a list. But
isolated words are not as strong as
words in context, embedded in sentences.
Always remember that as a first rule.
A simple yet very effective way to
memorize and learn new words is to
listen while reading. Think about it for
a second: you can for example read a text
as a beginner material or you can have
podcasts with scripts or movies with
subtitles. The most important thing is
that you listen while reading or reading
while listening. If you just listen to
the language without subtitles or a
script, you will not see the written word,
you will probably not understand if you
don't have a good level. On the other
hand, if you just read a text, you will
not see and hear how the language is
spoken, so you will miss out on the
spoken language. The easiest solution? Read
while listening as much as you can.
When you read a text in a foreign language
there's a very high chance that you're
going to stumble upon a lot of words
that you don't know. A very common
reaction is to try to strike and
underline and look up every single word
that appears on the text. I don't think
that this is an efficient way to deal
with it. A much more efficient way is to
focus just on the words that are
RELEVANT for you. Let me give you an
example: if you're an engineer, words such
as "tile" or "pillar" will probably be much
more interesting and relevant to you
than if you were a doctor for example,
and for a doctor some other words might
be more interesting, and anyway, the brain
discards a lot of words that it deems
not important. So just focus on ONE THIRD
of the unknown words that you find in
the text because the brain will remember
those words if they're relevant for you.
Heart, elephant and sand. If you think
about it, these simple words have a
constellation of elements around them.
For example you can say "(see) pink elephants"
or "the elephant in the room", "to draw a
line in the sand", "at the heart of the matter"
"golden heart", and so on and so forth.
This goes to show that the brain creates big
networks of associated elements and this
is how you can use your brain in order
to start learning new words. Every new
piece of information you can link it to
old pieces of information, so always make
sure that you look at words from this
perspective and think "how can I
associate this new piece of information
to the other pieces of information?" in
the network that I have talked about. And
this is the "word spiderweb" I was talking
about at the beginning of this video.
Some languages have notoriously long
words. Let's take the German word
"Freundschaftsbezeigung" which means "display of
friendship" but if you think about it, the
first reaction is to get scared by he
length of this word, but then when
looking closely, you will realize that
this word is made of "Freundschaft" -
- friendship -  and "Bezeigung" -
or "Bezeigungen" - display, displays of".
This makes the word easier to retain,
easier to pronounce, and easier to
remember. So get into the habit of
looking at words as made of smaller
parts. If you learn how these smaller
parts make longer words, things will get
much easier in terms of everything.
Romans used to say "Repetita juvant", which means "repeating helps" and that's
true, and that's what we do at college
university, at school: we tend to repeat
things over and over, but repeating
things in the very same way in which we
had been exposed to the very first time
is not actually a very efficient way of
dealing with texts. Let me give you a
metaphor: imagine that you have to
conquer a castle - that is, conquering the
language - if you always attack it through
the main door, the defendants will
realize your tactics and your strategy
and it will be easier to defend the
castle. If, instead, you attack the castle
from multiple angles, you are more likely
to win the battle. To give you a very
concrete example, if you listen while
reading the text the very first time that
you got exposed to it, three or four days
down the line, do things differently
maybe just listen to the text, or just
read it, or listen to it in the target
language while reading it in your own
native language.
Whatever is different is relevant and
it makes a big difference in the way our
brain retains information because we're
adding VARIETY to it. Novelty and
repetition is a fantastic combination to
retain words, texts, and whatever you want.
"Verba volant sed scripta manent",  "spoken words fly while written words stay"
another wise quote from the wise Romans. Why is this so relevant 2,000 years ago
as it is now? It's because words that are
spoken, they just fly around the air and you
need a system in place to catch them. So
always make sure that you have a device,
a note-taking device - be it your mobile
phone or your notebook - to catch these
words and these sentences on the fly. You
can do it everywhere. You can do it while
you're sitting and you're trying to
learn the language, and you can do it
while you're talking to your friends in
a bar, you can do it even while walking
and you come up with a word that you
want to know the meaning of in a
foreign language. Whatever it is, just
make sure that you have a notebook that
you can fit in your pocket
and you can carry it with you at all
times. And another tip is when you mark
words or sentences, always make sure that
you mark the PLACE and the TIME where
this happened, because it's going to give
you a very clear reference in time and
space for your episodic memory. It makes
a huge difference if you get into the
habit of doing this every single day.
This video contains a lot of information
and I've condensed it for the sake of
brevity and clarity. If you want to know
more, you can click on the link in the
description box below and you will be
able to read a very extensive article
about this very same topic. So here you
have it. These are the seven tools to
create and strengthen your "word
spider web". All you need to do now is to
get out there and catch as many "word
flies" as possible.